hi
just trying to find the lighting off the
perfect hotel oops hotel room lighting
okay you guys i'm gonna stop moving you
around i'm just gonna go set you
somewhere so i
haven't given you guys a little update
in a while um as you know i've been in
iceland freaking iceland how's this
how's that lighting not good
is that okay no
why don't you do what i tell you to do
camera no it's a bad angle you never
want to shoot yourself from below
because you look like a whale no now you
can't even see me at all okay i think
we're settled so i just wanna say hi i'm
actually in new york right now i've been
doing so much traveling lately and
that's nothing new i always say i'm
gonna stop traveling and just take a
little break and make youtube videos
which i mean i still make videos when
i'm traveling but it's so hard because
the amount of stuff that
i travel with i'm gonna show you this
picture of the stuff that i took with me
to iceland it was crazy me and my sister
were playing the roles of an entire film
crew we were editing we were shooting we
had lighting we had lobs we had all
kinds of microphones and it's quite a
process let me tell you for anybody who
thinks making youtube videos are easy
and if you are making youtube videos and
it is easy for you please give me all of
the tips because i'd like to know it
takes a lot of time
um actually i bought this bracelet
yesterday it's a chakra bracelet i
forget which one i got
um i'll look it up later
so i'm in new york we're announcing that
we're doing the second season of
hardwired so i'm pretty excited if you
guys missed the first season i'll put a
link in the description that you guys
can watch the first season i can't wait
it's been such a fun show to shoot the
first season was all about wearable
technology so like fitbits and brain
implants but this season we're going to
expand on not just wearables we're going
to kind of do
everything so we're calling it hardwired
2.0 because well season two 2.0 techie
and we're going to be shooting two
episodes this week we're doing the
announcement today so i can't wait i'm
so excited it's such a fun show no no my
brain fell out
i would like to talk about this curling
iron that i bought yesterday i've been
having to curl my hair lately because
it's so long that like when i wear it
straight it just looks like i'm wearing
a wig like it looks like i have a wig i
don't have a weave this is my hair it's
just long and
freaking
long so let me get the hold just can you
guys hold on a second oh no
i think the the maids must have thrown
the box away but i did take a picture so
this curling iron came with like this
free headband and they made it seem like
this headband was the most amazing
headband in the world it's
kind of terrible i don't know the box
was so funny it just made me laugh okay
maybe it's not that funny but i laughed
when i was purchasing it and the only
reason that i bought it is because there
was no other curling iron that i could
purchase at this place and the one that
i had here was broken so struggle is
real i love when people say the struggle
is real because most of the things that
people say that the struggle is real
it's not real like a freaking curling
iron is that what's the struggle there's
no struggle i'm thinking about doing an
advice segment because most of the
questions that i get from you guys is
like advice on
something i might not give the best
advice in the world but i have done a
lot of things i've met a lot of people
i've been in a lot of situations where
i've learned a lot of things and usually
every bad situation that i've been and
i've come out of that learning something
and when people ask me what is something
in your life that you wish that you
could take back and you could say
man i really wish that wouldn't have
happened i i
the complete honest answer to that is
there's nothing in my life that i would
ever say i wish that didn't happen
because everything that has happened
i've learned something i learned a lot
of things if you're going through
something right now it sucks it's gonna
suck it'll probably suck for a while may
not seem like it now but one day you're
gonna realize the thing that you learned
from that situation and be like huh yeah
i'm glad i know that now but if you make
the same mistake more than once
sometimes it takes people a few more
times to learn things that they need to
learn so it's okay
it happens
i said it again
for my flight home i'm trying to figure
out
what the next book is that i should read
i've actually loved all of your
suggestions and probably reading the
divergent series was one of my favorite
suggestions that you guys have suggested
for me by read i mean have read to me
i'm obsessed with audible like honestly
i don't know
how i did not discover this sooner
everyone is always like yeah i read such
and such book well guess what now i can
say i've read it too have read to me if
you guys want to get your free audible
book you can get one on audible.com
ijustine and you'll get a 30 day free
trial and all kinds of fun stuff let me
know what you guys think i should read
and let me know what you've read last i
actually have to head to a meeting right
now
i'm so sleepy jet lag is the craziest
thing being in iceland i was seven hours
ahead of my normal time and then i went
back to la for a week so just as i was
getting adjusted to that time zone now
i'm in new york i don't know about you
guys but i need sleep the thing about me
is i can sleep anywhere i can sleep
anywhere like you i will go outside
right now in the middle of this new york
street and i will freaking pass out in
the middle maybe maybe on the sidewalk
right in the concrete i could just mmm
those right off i used to
sleep under
desks in study hall in high school
i mean i would even bring like a little
travel pillow with me and i would just
curl right up and i'd always wear a
jacket the day that i knew that i would
have
a nice study hall so i could just curl
up underneath the desk people would be
doing work
i would also have my friends like sit in
front of me so that i could sleep and
the teacher wouldn't know i was there
although he knew i was there he's not
stupid most these people aren't stupid
like teachers are not dumb that's the
thing that we never realized when we
were young how we thought we were so
freaking smart like you guys right now
in school you probably think you're so
smart well guess what no it's not true
we're all stupid and these teachers know
exactly what they're doing they know
exactly what we were doing yeah okay
we're just gonna let you get away with
it but sometimes man when you do pull
one over on a teacher
it's the best feeling
bobby pins a bobby pin can never be
found when you need it it's like a
unicorn where's the unicorns i don't
know found one
i don't know i'm just rambling because i
actually really enjoy just sitting here
and
spewing out words at you guys i hope
that you enjoy it too thinking about
some more fun videos to make i do have a
cooking video coming up pancakes i have
a few more iceland vlogs i think those
will be going on my second channel i
gotta go do some stuff now here in the
city hopefully i'll run into some of you
guys on the street if you guys ever do
see me out in the wild please do say hi
cause that is the coolest thing to get
to see you guys and then i see your
pictures on twitter and you tweet them
to me and it's like we're best friends
so it's like we're freaking best friends
ever
see you later let me know what book you
guys end up getting with audible.com
god my hair looks great today can't wait
to curl my hair without weird freaking
curling iron okay i'll see you
you